[Music]
and welcome back everybody to a sick ass
episode of the careful boys exus me it
exat Mojo where we're doing the top 10
comprehensive list top 10 fight movies
ranked by us that everybody in the world
has to watch okay now that we have Mr
Jeremy over here nja Turtles 2 yeah
secret use secret secret of use for sure
Ys yum Ys
numbers to car and razar dude yeah
yeah after this that's the strongest
Choice I've ever seen made in a
movie Rock
Steady I love these guys they're not
even in that are they no but then I just
like them those guys are the the mutant
ugly babies they're babies but then
these guys are cool yeah I don't have
the other turt man I'm also say in top
10 as if we're going from like 10 to 1
and we already have our list but we're
just going to basically Rift what is it
what is it what is it what's number are
we going from least to greatest yeah we
got to go from 10 to one as if we
actually are that that good one of my
favorite of all time I don't know if you
guys watched it huh no he's going from
10 oh no he's going with favorite no no
this is one of my favorite from all time
but I I'm put started at 1 I'm putting
it at 10 because never watch watch it's
so Chinese I don't know if you guys have
seen it it's so you guys got to be
digging in the crates for this one all
right what is it you know um the is it
is it once upon a time in China I
think it's the one it's the one where um
the zombie guy yeah there's a there's a
metal there's a metal vampire dude he
rolls up in a [__] metal thing and
then his the move that he does like
he'll go up to shol and Mon and he goes
and he just goes and rips the shall like
I know what you're talking about I I've
seen that like clips of it I don't think
I think I watched the whole it's with
Jet Lee and that's why like that's one
of my favorite one but um I don't know
if if people have seen that one I think
the only way to come up with a list
today is if we all just keep shouting
them and we keep writing them and then
we take votes don't don't make it too
real but yes but yes here I'll I'll sort
of write it down don't make it too real
skip that one the one this one is
definitely either number nine or number
10 and it's Beverly Hills Ninja Beverly
Hills Ninja is a banger D Beverly Hills
Ninja's amazing for the scene where he's
trying to act like the Benny Hana
guy he's like freestyling his dumbass
[__] yeah where does the liveaction
street fighter land oh number 11 dude
wants to go home and who wants to come
with me I'm going to kick his ass so
hard so hard that's what he says next
bison is going to f it he says bison wab
be bison line to Chun Lee was pretty
fire though what does he say when he
tells him like I I killed your father
like and you remember but to me it was a
Tuesday that was he was good dude what
was his name r Julia dud it's freaking
Gomez combat up there though OG MK the
first one the first one and then
Annihilation was O okay cuz like after
ready to cut his hair was all right no
but there was cool fights in it there
were there were remember Subzero without
the mask that was pretty cool I mean the
the intro scene was crazy yeah mhm like
the backstory of like Scorpion and yeah
yeah no the the first two were cool what
did you like the newer
one I love hio Yuki sonada he's tight at
scorpion he's tight that alone was like
the best marketing for that whole movie
yeah that opening scene was that the
opening scene they dropped that whole
opening scene on YouTube before the
movie came that was hard bro but that
was the the only best kind of well the
gore in general was really fun yeah yeah
yeah it was like okay cool but I didn't
know that was the story between Subzero
and Scorpion I don't know like I didn't
know oh yeah I feel like there's always
like a different version of it like it
always changes have you guys ever seen
Showdown it's a Billy Blanks martial
arts
movie I really liked this movie is he is
he doing aerobics while he's no it's so
typical tyo get it
right it's in like it was a 1993 movie
and it's a what happens in the plot is
that it's like a high school and of
course these bullies are beating on this
kid and then he's the janitor that sees
it and he's like you got to toughen up
and he like teaches him how to fight
that's tight but then the it turns out
the bullies are like part of The
Syndicate like gang so then they're
going after the janitor guy now sounds
like kind of back down like kind of back
down kind of back down back down it
sounds like a kind of back down it's
like a like a bad version of it kind of
back down kind of back down I might back
down what about the raid ra raid is raid
is tight
yeah iMed Game Changer immediately top
five top five but see as a fight
coordinator in the space I hated the
raid for the fact that I couldn't go
into like a meeting with a director or
producer that says like that doesn't
bring it up like I want this to look
like the raid you know I'm like every
every show what do they mean by that
when they say that what are they
specifically trying to say little
Indonesian
people well they're like you know the
like you know I like for a long time it
was like you're you're pretty young I've
never really heard of but like you know
like I the style I want is like real
real like the raid like real brutal and
it's like for 10 years it was like I
want my movie to look like the raid but
I'm not going to give you an actor to to
train for you know a month it's always
two weeks but I want them to look like
the raid oh the movie The Raid was made
by Indonesian people who had been doing
martial arts all their
life if they wanted to make a movie in
two weeks that could be done but like
you want me to take somebody who is the
best romcom actor or something and make
them look like the ra make Ryan goling
do [__] more tie the right way he did
a movie too though didn't he uh grey man
yeah grey man what you think of that um
I don't know I think the movie itself
like had a lot like things that didn't
quite you know yeah it felt like it felt
like a kind of a John Wick adjacent or
like they were trying to go for John wi
yeah yeah well that's the other thing
too as soon as John Wick came out
everybody wanted us to do John Wick's
stop every trying to do gun fu yeah and
so that you know when I have a
Bittersweet with these like best fight
scenes like the newer ones right cuz
what's like a stunt man's movie kind of
like I feel like the fighters movie hot
rod
hot my favorite is so funny well you
know that Arnold's in there the first
stunt when he goes over the the van and
hits the the ramp that guy like broke
both of his femurs oh my God went to the
hospital and and then won an award for
it oh [__] he won like hard as hit wow
dude break both your femurs that's
insane think like a Canadian guy he was
in Canada well at least got a ward for
it bro that [__] was brutal that's the
two strongest bones in your body and
they both broke at the same timeck go
watch just go and watch that clip again
and it's [__] up when he's in the air
you're like that's a real person and
then he hits and you're like he looks
like a doll cuz his legs are just going
like this G and you're like oh something
went wrong the comedy relief is him
going and he throws up everywhere it
like a standard thing I always wondered
that when when you guys are shooting a
scene and the stunt guy gets seriously
injured or Worse do they normally not
want to use that shot now for the
film uh no I wish I mean but no okay
it's sensitive subject right because
when somebody gets hurt you're like out
of respect I don't want to use it but if
I got hurt Hur in a shot I would hope
that it was good enough to get make the
movie so that I didn't do it for nothing
be kind of worse but like I want to die
in a in a movie and be
memorialized by putting up a real death
in the scene well don't [__] edit
that part I die for nothing I think the
prince of Morocco was in like number
three in week three and he wanted to die
on movies so bad like he just came in
put on thing CH let him take like a
gunshot that's Point yeah so it's one of
the random guys who just gets shot but
doesn't do a fight it was the prince of
Morocco holy [__] it's nuts that's TI
that's insane what the [__] yeah so you
for your own personal if that something
happened to you you definitely would
want it in the film I would want it in
the film one of my favorite fight scenes
what's the movie where the guy has the
[__] legs oh drunk Master yeah yeah
that's one of my favorite fight
sces yeah fa ever what's that Turkish
action film where that guy kicks and and
makes gunshot noises and he's by the
pool and he's [__] like 30 dudes up
going Turkish yeah it was like action
what about yoga Kung Fu you seen that
guy yoga Kung Indian guy they're trying
to capture him with those little zip
those ties you got oh what after we're
going from top 10 to
Wild best I think those are better I
want to hear some deep cuts yoga Kung Fu
that [__] was crazy cuz he actually does
some legit amazing stuff do you have any
favorite Sten Chow films for
fighting not off the top of my head she
doesn't like Stephen and you're
scratching the top your head I'm just
really he they're coming out with the
new solent silent soccer yeah the shin
women soccer yeah you sound excited I
don't think it makes sense I like it I
don't think it makes sense cuz of the in
original Shon soccer the women saved the
day already so it's kind of so then the
guy's going to save the day this time
God bringing a mang goalie see how it
happens I rather see girls and girls
soccer outfits and guys I don't want to
see guys and short shorts and lock socks
what about guys and girl soccer
outfits that's
gay oh do you like blade blade That's a
classic I don't like blade too though
just one I like blade really cuz he
brings like a special swag to today's
video is brought to you by Factor what's
up everybody does this ever happen to
you oh I am a very busy entrepreneur or
a student doing homework and then you go
oh I'm so hungry well let me look in my
fridge oh my gosh there's no Mom or
Grandma here to get food ready you know
this is going to take a long time you
know you got to go and clean some dishes
and plates well have no fear factor is
here you see this this only takes 2
minutes to make and they got really
delicious stuff this one's sundried
tomato
chicken and this one yo for all my
vegans out there right here you see
that this
one vegan mushroom Masala I had a bunch
of these
myself they got smoothies they got meal
prepped ready to go it comes straight to
your door so if you are a busy digital
Nomad if you are a entrepreneur or if
you just like gaming for 14 hours
straight and you don't live with your
grandma that will cook you food and you
want food really quick because you
forget to eat well this is the perfect
meal for you 2 minutes in the microwave
and then you can feed yourself and get
back to doing what you've been doing in
life so head to factor meals
/of
thc50 and use code offord 50 to get
50% off that's code off theere
@f Factor meals.com off the Record 50 to
get
50% off thank you factor very much for
not only keeping me well fed but
sponsoring jaen news they shower in the
blood has nothing to do with
vampires is just so fun yeah the blood
just
coming oh when homie gets chopped and
the CGI if you watch it now you're like
this is
ridiculous but it's so sick though I
just I remember like when he threw the
when he threw the blade and then it went
all the way around and he caught it
again I was like I was like how do you
do that I was like a kid I was like
that's
DP probably the easiest thing he shot in
the whole movie he like whip pan off wh
back
that was so cool man that still hold the
easiest thing here one of my favorites
is best of the best best of the best bro
you know who trains with me as a stu guy
now Philip re's son Sean
Shan a
bunch he is Philip son do [__] Legend
oh did you ever see the movie Tough Turf
it's it's like Philip Reed it's like a
movie that was such a deep cut like so
many people haven't seen it the movie
looks like it's completely gorilla shot
the whole time it's so dark is that
where he's like with the kids like uh a
teaching kids or it's like it's like him
and his friend are they go to like a
community college but they get bullied
or something and then so they end up
having they end up getting hired as
security for like a party and then at
the party they see these guys doing a
Coke deal and then they steal the the
Coke or the money or something they
intervene oh God it gets crazy but the
movie itself is really good it's it had
two titles Tough Turf and not Tough Turf
I'm sorry ninja turf or La Street
Fighters those were the two names I'm
going to have to watch that I think did
yeah but I haven't met one other person
that's seen it one other person that's
because sha re posted it once like him
and his dad with the poster and I was
like that's the coolest [__] oh dude
that's so cool that is cool being in a
movie with Dad yeah well no he's not in
it with his dad but it's not cool
anymore the only person that could find
that has seen it is his
son Philip re hasn't even seen it dude
yeah actually SE uh Philip and Simon re
are going to be on our one of our o um
the next onecast how cool we shot we
shot it the same day with Jemma and
Steve so oh right on yeah that's going
to come out and what was funny is like I
look at them as like these old school
dudes but you know they're so nice dude
they came in and we were just shooting
the [__] right away and I was like
they're [__] I haven't met B but Sim
I've met Simon a couple times and to his
dojo and he's really nice one of the
nicest guys in the world I wish he had
an iPad you know what I did though I
like when we started talking about best
of best I started doing the I now offer
myself brother and they were both at
first they were both like what is no way
and like their realization and I just
stayed in it too and then they were like
they're like wow they're like do you
want me to [__] you
up that movie that you showed me for
that that old jet Lea film I was like I
never heard of that that's a crazy deep
cut have you ever watched a jet Lea film
called the master the master yeah yeah
yeah it's super old school do you know
which one cuz I'm name him wrong he
comes from China with the no no no so he
comes from China cuz um he comes to
China cuz his old Master Now teach has
like a herbal store in America the
minute he gets off a bus three cholos
are like hey fool these guys are rich so
he comes and Jacks his duffel bag yeah
they steal his duffel bag and jetley is
just on foot chasing this [__] low
rider down and then there's and there's
this one where this one scene where he's
going down the parking lot like this
jetley like jumps like through the
middle and they're like oh [__] that
[__] guy's crazy hey and then there's
like a white uh like some that the
Master's former student that was a white
guy now is like a terror in town he's
challenging all these martial arts
schools he beats the [__] up everyone
and then Jet Ley is the other like
student so it's kind of like student on
like new uh current student on old
student he has to fight to like avenge
his old Master guys ever seen it that
narrows that down to like 10 jet Le
movies the the best thing is that the
cholos become his disciples and he
teaches the cholos how to fight and they
become like Kung Fu cholos bro so I have
to watch this movie and he make this do
they still dress like Kung
fuos be a spin-off movie called Kung Fu
cholos Contraption with like basketballs
and [__] [__] bungee cord and [__]
and then like they have to like hit it
it was like training yeah like some of
the actually part that part was freaking
amazing like really creative but the
weird thing is that you could so tell
one of the cholos is so clearly a guy
from jackiechan stunt team that you've
seen a million times so you're like this
guy's not Mexican at all a skin it's
like the dude you've seen him in every
movie it's like Armor of God where they
had the four Chinese guys playing the
Amazonian women
oh Armor of God like the with the black
wig and they're like they're all wearing
like spaghetti straps yeah they're
getting kicked off the stairs and [__]
yeah that's sounds awesome yeah Armor of
God now we're just going to like the
weird movies that we've seen the
Master's good though the marshal arts is
really really
good I always like anything with uh like
some of dian's later stuff with like
flasho like those fight scenes are so
cool there's one fight yeah SPL is
really sick or anything with Sam o hung
and Donnie Sam he's like the most
athletic fat dude ever I'll watch just
cuz he's like a bigger dude and the way
he moves is incredible dude you ever
seen Donan and mismatched couples yes oh
dude I have a story about that what yeah
so I fight coordinated Tri XX 3 where
Donnie was on set that's sick and like
when I was trying to like get him to put
his like guard down I remember one day
we were trying to come up with ideas cuz
he didn't like the idea we'd put
together it's like Jeremy I need six
options now I'm like okay so we can do
this we can do that and just started
throwing him at him and he's like wo wo
wo wo and then at the end I was like or
we could do this and I was doing his
like little bit no and I started like
you Donnie's right there and I'm
like and he's just like
man and then later he goes he goes
Jeremy he like yes yes Doo he's like
you're Filipino aren't you like yes sir
he goes man so much
style so much Filipinos have so much
style and just walked away that's so
dope so yeah that was my first time that
was the first time I worked with him
that's [__] sick that's the movie
that's the movie where like breaking was
like and popping was like so hot that
they like practically made him like do
all that [__] is that the clip where
he's like putting on his
jeans I don't know I didn't I never
though he's like I never knew if it was
true but when I went to China I kept
asking people how I could buy that DVD
cuz it's like they never made the DVD
available like localized so you can only
get like weird bootleg versions and they
were like oh they don't we don't have it
around here I guess like I don't know if
it's true that he he doesn't want people
to see that one now oh man so it doesn't
get like
distributed CU he didn't like his dance
moves he goes I'm so bad at a popping
and locking now he was good but it's
probably not part he probably doesn't
like it it's his legacy I think he that
a part of his legacy yeah I think he's
hit that that that like place where he
wants to be the master and he is a
master and I wish he could just
understand that if we all knew that side
of him that it would make him even more
of a master nor yeah cuz even on set now
like when when he's in the middle of set
he holds himself differently a little
bit in than way offet he way offet he's
joking and stuff but on set he's fun and
he's personable but he's also very
reserved like like he's just like yeah
I'm up I'm the master like and I'm like
yeah but the master who could also
[__]
bre TI yeah to me I love it so I love
that movie so much man so good and then
they put they try to be sneaky and put
the trampoline in the car yeah yeah
jumping on the car on the roof of the
car
like okay I don't know about that it's
just full of gags it's like silly but
it's so relatable what was it called
mismatched couples it's actually not a
good movie but the the funny scenes are
are really good it was the one where
he's dancing right he's like doing a
dance B I've seen that one those are the
parts that anyone's ever seen like when
you watch it as a full movie you're like
what's the rest of this what is
this so we've named like six I like the
first it man way more cuz the first the
the one where he fights the northerner
that scene is crazy and then the one
when he fights the guy at the end that's
that was crazy or when he just goes
against all the karate guys in general
in that [__] you formation
I like the uh three or three or four
where he's fighting the Muay Tha guy in
the elevator and he's like saving his
wife oh oh
yeah it's one of my favorites cuz you
see the [__] stunk guy doing the Muay
Thai and he's doing stair Falls with no
shoes on and you're like that
sucks cuz usually on a stfall like you
smash your feet to bits if you're like
if you're doing a really good one like
if you're doing a fast one and he's just
doing it with no sh
shoes dude that does suck but super
super cool I like Story one is always a
good one story the one where the the
stunt the famous stunt that got botched
where they fly off the top of the bus
and they miss the car oh oh yeah and
they landed on their like tailbones oh
God imagine Jesus Christ this might be
more of a legendary cultural one but
there's Game of Death Game of Death Game
of Death is sick the fight scenes I
really like the fight scenes Le going up
the [__] thing finding Kare like the
Kareem one was wow cuz it's like such a
big difference I think Bruce Lee though
is in a category that like doesn't like
he shouldn't be allowed to make lists
yeah that's true he like oh yeah of
course gave him to death that's just
like the Bible there's the list and then
there's the beyond the right beyond the
list for sure that's good let me take
them off
this he's like we know he's on the list
yeah he's on the same L with like Blood
and Bone and stuff huh like in
I'm just
[Laughter]
kidding to look you cold in the face
while saying
that with enough with JLo wait is that
the one with is that the one with
Michael J white the never backed out
that's the fighters movie the fighters
fighters yeah Michael yeah all right so
we've got in no particular order Once
Upon A Time In China with the zombie we
got Beverly Hills Ninja uh the
liveaction street fighter Mortal Kombat
the raid Drunken Master 2 blade best of
the best itman police story with
honorable mentions of the master Armor
of God yoga Kung Fu and mismatch
cou it's a pretty bad
list watch
Mojo what's that one movie when they
when um [__] when he [__] when is it
Jackie Chan when he fights that that one
kickboxer the ugly ass [__] like
this was like in the 70s it was a solid
scene Benny the jet jet Meals on Wheels
you you just called him the ugly he is
scary looking though Benny the jet does
look like the jet looks [__] have you
ever have you ever worked with him or
like you haven't worked with him but I'm
met him he's super nice I have a picture
with
him Vis Bradley Martin opened his first
gym zoo in uh like North Hollywood area
um I went to go visit him and then I
just saw like a karate St a karate
studio right next door and then I was oh
I'm going just walk by I always like Jet
Center uh it I forgot what it said but I
walked in I was like what the [__]
that's Benny the jet yeah and I just
went in I was like hey I'm a huge fan
want to say hi and then I I shook his
hand and then I I went back into
Bradley's gym and I'm like yo Bradley
I'm like do you know your Gym's next to
a legendary Marshall artist he's like no
dude that's [__] crazy dang oh what
do you think about the Tony jaw movies
onb yeah onok and protector I mean I
liked all his his older movies like
obviously I was like 14 and I was like
could do it could do it the first time I
ever saw like [__] like Muay Tha
forms though well I really liked it cuz
it wasn't like there was a time where
like for me martial arts is kind of like
Styles you know like music and like I
was like I hate Kung Fu now it's too
fake and then Tony jock came out like
wow wow and I was like and then all the
slow MOS you're like he really hit that
dude like yeah that was thing about it
right at that time everywhere too cuz I
feel like there was a LOL in action
movies and then that movie at the time
just came out of nowhere and you're like
what the [__] is this and then I doubled
him oh yeah on Triple X oh that's sick
is he truly really [__] people up in
those movies like they're getting hurt
he has really good control I think in
Thailand you can get away with stuff but
when we shot trip x 3 we were in um
Toronto and he had a lot of control so
wow I think the only time he really
fully connected was when he was doing
doing the flying double knee and it was
like yeah you got to do that Pat up take
it and it was like good luck and he
saved an elephant yeah got good hops huh
hops cuz all his scenes are [__]
crazy but it was funny cuz when we were
choreographing together he's like he's
like jermy maybe we just do you know my
specials and you do specials here cuz I
was trying to choreograph something
different and then he goes like the side
swipe like this I go oh you could add a
hook to it and then I would do it he
goes
you could do my
stuff he I was like don't act like you
don't watch tricking videos dude CU you
tricking doesn't come from with Tha man
like in my head I was like I I remember
back in the day there was like a forum
called Club 540 and somebody was like no
Tony jaw watches our
forums so I was like oh maybe whatever
maybe he does maybe he doesn't but when
he found out that I could do all his
like signature moves anytime he had an
idea for the director he goes he
realized he didn't have to like show
people stuff cuz he'd be like oh we do
this like we were in a graveyard one
time doing a chase scene and we were
having he's like maybe I'm chasing him
and he opens the car door and then I do
uh it's like 700 in the morning he's
like Jimmy yes sir he goes you know do
my special the split you're the demo guy
now and I couldn't do split since I was
12 right and we're on gravel and the car
door opens I had to do the splits under
the car door being opened because holy
[__] next to another car and he goes
what do you think about this and he goes
go Jeremy show them like 7 a.m. I do the
[__] sliding splits and I'm hoping
the the gravel slides me enough to just
clear my head cuz if I lift my head too
soon I get hit so I just feel the the
door go like this and I go okay I'm
clear stand up and I take off and I'm
like I didn't know I could do the
splits yeah no he made he just made me
do everything to show the director it
was cool and then he did everything
thing himself
but I just have
[Music]
random